I'm Jad Abumrad are you asleep?
Hey. Hi. Do I even know
where you are right now?
Did you see like one day with my
leg? Why I kicked myself awake?
Did you see that? I heard
it. I'm Jab, boom, rod. Oh,
I'm Robert Krulwich and our next
falling feature is falling asleep,
but with a little kick. This
is Radiolab. Let's do it. Well,
tell me your name first and just tell me
how you would like to be identified on
here. You can call me Fred.
I like it the best. Okay.
My full title is Professor
Frederick l Coolidge,
University of Colorado
at Colorado Springs.
So just so we get our definitions
right. What is a hypnic jerk?
It appears to be this, what seems to be
a reflex. Everybody's experienced it.
It's, it's you're still semi-conscious.
Then you start to feel kind of dreamy.
You start to feel this
loosening of your thoughts,
loosening of, of your reality.
But just as you're about to go under,
he says, just the first onset of sleep,
Bam, one big jerk. Then you're awake.
Usually you wake up with this feeling of
like, oh my God. Oh my God, Oh my God.
Oh, all right. And you know, wait,
how did you start studying this?
I was working at Kentucky Fried Chicken.
Can I say it on the air for a dollar,
for a dollar an hour.
And I just thought, man,
I still can't eat coleslaw to this day
cause I would do a hundred pounds of
Coleslaw a day. So, um,
I saw this ad on campus and it said
somebody to work in a sleep lab.
So I went and applied and I ended up
in the beginning cleaning toilets.
But I just got into all asleep.
I thought it was fascinating and I got
fascinated by these giant jerks at the
beginning of sleep. And I said, what
is that? You know? And they said, oh,
that's a hypnic jerk. And I said, what
is that? And they said, that's a hypnic.
In other words, no one could really
explain to him why these things happen.
That's right. So he started poking
around and there were some theories,
you know, having to do with
like physiological changes
in your body, you know,
a lowering of oxygen content
or something like this.
And you put that kind of
explanation didn't really satisfy.
It really doesn't say, well why,
what was its function? And, um,
as I started to look at the literature,
I saw that we had a very long
history sleeping in trees.
If we go back to Australopithecus
afarensis this is Lucy.
3 million years ago, Lucy was by
pedal. I mean walking on two legs.
Lucy lived in the trees. But
unlike the other prime itch,
she would sometimes go down to the ground.
But on the ground you've got big
bird, you've got snakes, tigers,
and rough times.
That ground life was stressful.
But night she crawled
up the tree for safety.
She climbed up in that tree,
drops food there for her baby and
she's going to drop off to sleep.
Her muscles loosen her hands on curl.
She starts to have that relaxation.
Pretty soon she can't feel the tree
under her back or que the noises
down below. Just stay with me.
[inaudible] okay. That she
feels like she's floating
or falling, falling, falling. That means
I'd be a real good idea
to wake up from that.
Sleep was such a dangerous proposition
for so many millions of years that
something like the hypnic jerk, if some
of those primates had that behavior,
they may have been just slightly more
likely over millions of years to to adapt
and survive and we haven't gotten
rid of it yet is what he's saying.
So that's my jerk is just basically so
I don't get eaten by a lion all these
many years. Yeah, that's what he's
saying. Sort of like a Lucy Echo.
Do we know this or we just a mad
no. How are we going to know this?
This is just a story,
but there is at least one a tantalizing,
a bit of evidence to support this
idea. You ask college students,
what are the most common dreams that
you have and falling to is number one or
number two most common theme. And
if you go on a college campus,
you know thanks to OSHA, right? You
have no chance of falling off anything.
They'll make sure that your fullest
drop is like a flutter, six inches.
Even then at big yellow and red signs
all over it, but they dream of falling.
What, and by the way, the next
most common dream after falling,
it's being chased by an
alien in a blue dress.
Nobody is gonna stay
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
[inaudible] I'm wondering what happened
been falling.
Why is it that elderly people fall down
a lot? If you go into any hospital ward,
you'll see lots and lots of elderly people
who are in there with broken hips and
things like that because
they've, they've fallen.
So I started asking my clinician
friends and they say, wow,
they have a poor sense of balance,
muscle weakness. And I said,
could it have anything to do with
timing? What do you mean? Well,
one of the things I study is how the
brain sends out signals to the whole body
and how these signals come back.
Because the strange part is the brain is
situated all the way at one end of the
body all the way at the top end.
And it's controlling this huge amount of
machinery you have to send signals all
the way out to the toes
and all the way back.
And they're surprisingly
slow in the brain.
It's about 300,000 times slower than
singles move around in a computer.
So it would be like if you were a NASA
operator controlling the Mars rover,
there's a delay between when you send the
[inaudible] seven signals and when you
get the feedback, when you get feedback.
And so what happens is the brain is very,
it puts a lot of effort into making
sure that it knows exactly the timing of
sending signals out and when it's getting
signals back, and that's how you walk.
For example,
do you want the camera? Can
I take it? The camera? Oh,
this is like what toddlers
learn in reversed.
Aren't they learning the timings to get
the left foot out in front of the right.
That's exactly what they're doing.
They're calibrating the timing
of their whole nervous system.
That's interesting.
Cause that my kid's 10 months old and I
think he's in this calibrating periods
stand up. So what's happening
with him now is he's standing,
but then it looks like he's about to
take a step. But then right, it's about,
oh, that was a little
spill. Yes, it's good.
So basically you're saying his little
brain is trying to figure out the timing
on, let me see it. Oh,
electricity racing from brain to
foot and foot back to brain. Yes.
Mission control is going right.
Okay. Sending that message to the feet,
we expect it back in 300 milliseconds.
So
the fall take three. Okay, we're going
to try now. Two 80 milliseconds. Okay.
Two 80
ran down to Ooh, tumble
fall. That's exactly right.
A lot of trial and error until you get
the timing right, but get it right.
Now you're a walker, right?
How many?
Now something that happens in let's say
multiple sclerosis and maybe also when
you get old says David,
is that the timing starts to change
because there's damage to the Xi thing
around the nerves and that
slows down certain signals.
So then the brain says, oh, I thought my
foot should have hit the ground by now,
but it hasn't. So I'm going to send
out a corrective motor command.
And then finally the signal does come
back and you've set out this corrective
motor command and you'll
stumble with each step.
You fall forward slightly.
And then catch yourself
from falling.
Now we are going to fall far from home.
We're going to have to travel a good
many late years off the planet to fall in
this particularly special and gruesome
way. Our father is Neil degrasse Tyson.
He's a astronomical
physicist. Is that what he is?
Here he is at the Herbst theater.
I like saying that [inaudible] theater
in San Francisco in front of an audience
talking about
falling apart. Um, my name,
my own business on the airplane and
someone looks and sees what I'm doing.
They find out I do astrophysics,
the outcome, the questions.
When will life end?
Will the asteroid com, will the Aztec
calendar destroy the earth? There's all,
there's, it goes on and on.
So I figured people like death in mayhem,
so I might as well title the book with
that because there's a whole chapter on
how to die as you fall into a black hole,
which I personally think it's a
kind of kind of cool way to die
because what happens is the gravity
of the black hole is extreme.
As you can imagine, light
doesn't even escape.
Its gravity is so extreme light
traveling at the speed of light.
All right? So if light doesn't come
out, nothing's coming out. It's black.
You fall in, you're not coming
out. It's a one way trip. Okay,
so you don't just die cause you disappear.
You die long before you disappear.
As you fall in,
the gravity at your feet becomes rapidly
greater than the gravity at your head.
So your feet start falling
faster than your head does.
That's a bad situation to be in.
You don't really know initially
you kind of feel good, you know,
cause it's every you, we all stretch.
When you wake up in the morning.
Initially it feels like a stretch.
But what happens is that stretch continues
beyond comfort levels and you reach a
point where, and they're called the
tidal forces, tides on your body.
Basically the tidal force comes so great
that they exceed the intermolecular
forces that bind your flesh.
And so the point comes where you snap
into two pieces likely to happen at the
base of your spine. Now you
are two pieces. No. Now,
I know you didn't ask about this, but
it turns out you will survive that
snap because below your waist,
while there are the important organs,
there are no vital
organs below your waist.
So your torso will stay
alive for a little while,
okay? Until you bleed to death.
But this all happens much faster
than it would take to bleed to death.
So these two pieces then feel tidal
forces and then they snap into two pieces
and then they snap again into eight and
then 16 and then you're bifurcating your
way down. And so eventually it's
your head and multiple other parts.
And so that will continue until you are
a stream of Adams descending toward the
abyss. And it turns out
that's not the worst of it.
Okay? The worst,
it turns out the fabric of space and
time funnels down towards a black hole.
So the space that you occupy up here is
larger than a space you occupied down
here. So in fact, you're getting,
while you're getting stretched,
you getting screened,
extruded through the fabric
of space like toothpaste.
[inaudible]
well, we're, we're about to fall away.
I think we can it. Yeah. Okay. Nice.
One Nice one. [inaudible]
before we do though. Uh, no,
that we have podcasts. It's a radio
lab.org and Gen ed. Boom. Rod. I remember.